it just feels like we're completely
overrun and we've lost control of
everything at least I know that that
here it's you're helpless you're
helpless and those people that say that
we don't have a problem you come live in
Eagle Pass for a few weeks and you'll
see it and you'll understand how awful
and insecure it feels I've been a member
of the community for over 50 years I'm a
second generation owner to a barbecue
business in town that it's called The
Wagon Wheel we are off the main highway
I also have a property as well that's
been in the family for over 26 years and
I've just not only has my business been
broken into and ransacked it's just the
insecurity now you know you don't feel
safe at home anymore I worked alongside
my father for 19 years one break-in in
25 years
from February to now
I've had five
I I I don't know how to secure my
building
enough to keep these people away
all right people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's September 20th
2022. we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and Blaze TV subscribe if you
have not already and the reason we did
that cold open you know usually I go for
a kind of silly or funny or meme worthy
cold open but I saw that clip going
viral yesterday and then into this
morning it's a it's a Fox Nation clip
talking about a Border Town Eagle Pass
Texas uh and they're telling the story
of the people there that are having
their towns overrun by illegal
immigrants these are stories that you
will not hear anywhere in Mainstream
other than on Fox and these are
certainly stories that you will not hear
on uh or you will not hear any Democrat
or Progressive politician talk about so
I thought that was an interesting way to
frame a little bit of today's show
because it's like man we had we had
three days of absolute Insanity because
50 people got to Martha's Vineyard and
quickly 150 in effect soldiers National
Guard kicked him out the Martha's
Vineyard people didn't want them we
didn't have the resources Chuck Todd
talking about this island with no
infrastructure we've got to help these
people but there is real damage
happening to real
people so I thought that was an
interesting way to just start the show
today because what I want to really talk
about today is the the two directions
that the country seems to be going in
right now and one is a direction roughly
of Sanity Clarity something based on
fact in reality and one is completely
insane and we are all going to have to
decide which which of those roads that
we're going to go down I suspect that
you and I are going to go down the same
road but a lot of people just aren't uh
and speaking of people that aren't and
that have been leading us down that road
of insanity uh Gavin Newsom
California governor Gavin Newsom I'm
putting money in the jar
there are some insiders saying that he
is getting ready to run for president
that basically he knows Biden isn't
going to do it you remember he showed up
at the White House when Biden was off in
Europe a month or two ago and that he is
pretty much going to push Biden out and
then use Kamala as his number two uh
that will be in stark contrast to say
perhaps Iran DeSantis running for
president but that is the split it's not
just about the two guys it's about the
ideology and maybe maybe that is just
the fight that America has to have it
has to have the are we going to be
California or or are we going to be
Florida maybe that's the fight America
as that's what we're going to be talking
about today oh and real quick uh after
the show today I am pre-taping
tomorrow's show which will be a q a live
at 11 o'clock as always taped live and
then we put it live something like that
that and then I am off to
we're going dare I say it we're going to
Los Angeles tonight uh I am doing Bill
Maher's podcast tomorrow I'm going to do
some stuff with prageru during the day
I'm doing the fighter and the kid
podcast with Brian Callan and Brandon
Schwab uh but the per the main purpose
of the trip uh is to do Bill Maher's
podcast we will see what we get into I
am looking forward to talking to him
I'll try to Red Pill him a little bit
more I know they don't want it to be
fully focused on politics they want it
to be kind of personal because it has to
be obviously a little bit different than
than the real time show but I have my
marching orders that I've given myself
and I look forward to chatting with the
guy who I've admired a lot all the years
and although we have some political
differences it really doesn't matter and
hopefully we can make something really
uh really worthwhile come out of it and
maybe it'll start a continued back and
forth that's what I would really hope
for more than anything else I don't
think I'm going to walk in there and you
know he's going to walk out like all
right moving to Florida and I'm voting
for DeSantis I don't think we can we're
going to quite get there but we might
get to a place where it's like you know
what for an hour and a half two hours we
had a pretty good conversation you're a
decent guy I'm a decent guy we were very
similar say a couple years ago gone in
our different direction so to speak but
but the the base of what we want is kind
of similar and we should continue with
these conversations so that is my hope
and then I will be getting on a red eye
and Thursday morning I am dinging the
bell at NASDAQ that's right Rumble as
you guys probably know if you watch the
show yesterday if you're in the
financial world uh Rumble and of course
we started locals locals eventually
merged with Rumble Rumble is now a
publicly traded company on NASDAQ rum so
we'll be drinking a lot of Mojitos over
the next couple days uh and Free Speech
has gone public
um and I'm very excited about that so
pretty freaking cool you know I had this
idea three years ago about creating a
little tech company so I could get off
the pipes and eventually and just within
three short years and it was a freaking
hell of a lot of work getting investors
building Tech dealing with the Free
Speech issues the legal issues the
headaches all of the stuff but Rumble is
now public and I'm and I'm dinging the
Bell so uh I'm really psyched about that
that's at 9 30 a.m on Thursday oh and
then we're live at 10 A.M right
yes we are live at 10 A.M I think we're
gonna do about a two hour show live from
the NASDAQ floor we'll see who what
guests I can get and they've got an
awesome Studio there should be really
cool so anyway a lot of good energy
around here I'm feeling good about the
world I know there are little headaches
but it's all going to be okay uh let's
talk about bully and Max and then we'll
get to it uh you know as inflation
surpasses highs not seen in 40 years the
value of the dollar is decreasing with
every passing day you're paying more at
the pump the grocery store for cars for
housing face it paper money is worth
less friends the time couldn't be any
better for my new sponsor bullion Max
bullion Max is a direct to Consumer
precious metals retailer who can help
you diversify into gold and silver it's
a hedge against inflation it's also
security for your family in times of
Crisis and here's why I love bullion max
they're owned by veterans in the
precious metals space offer some of the
lowest prices on the internet and they
make it so easy to buy directly from
their website I want to help you get
started so I worked out a special offer
with them just for you go to bullying
Mac get bullion Max a silver starter kit
at employee pricing just go to
bullionmax.com Dave this kit includes
five of the most desirable silver
products to invest in including a silver
American eagle and a silver Australian
kangaroo this offer is limited to just
one per household so get yours now go to
bullionmax.com Dave and now back to me
okay so let's get to it Lizard Man Gavin
Newsom a man who has done nothing but
destroy everything he touches although
he personally gets very wealthy and gets
his houses and Estates and wineries but
he destroyed San Francisco as the mayor
has destroyed California as the governor
well now it looks like he is going to
push Joe Biden out and he will run for
president we've got some info from the
New York Post California governor Gavin
Newsom is undeniably unequivocally
preparing to seek the Democratic
Presidential nominee in 2024 a
nomination in 2024 if President Biden
decides not to run for a second term and
is poised to take on vice president
Kamala Harris according to report on
Monday Newsom who recently challenged
Florida's Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis to a debate over his sending 50
migrants to Martha's Vineyard plans to
make an announcement after the midterm
elections once the president relays his
intentions the rap reported no ifs and
or buts he will run if Biden does not a
leading California fundraiser told the
outlet so first off
I want to start just broadly talking
about what's going on here I I when this
came across my desk this morning I
thought well should we run this story
because it's a little bit of political
conjecture and you know a source said
this and blah blah blah this feels legit
to me this feels fully legit even if you
just go back to a day or two ago when
Joe Biden was on 60 Minutes and they did
that very highly edited interview it's
clear that he is not sure if he's going
to run I still for I said it that when
he got inaugurated and I still believe
it I don't think he will even make it to
the end I think it's broken down much
faster than people thought and I also
think and and this one is a Hope on my
part I want that red wave to be so
strong I want the Republicans to get
back the house and the Senate and I
believe it should and will happen
barring covet 9 monkey pox zombie
apocalypse dropping a nuke on Ukraine
you know like some of the crazy stuff
they can do but if the Republicans do
really well in the midterms which again
as you guys know in the off years the
off election years the the incumbent the
presidency uh always does poorly their
party always does poorly it happens to
everybody they will need someone to
blame and then they will all just look
at Old Joe Biden and they will just say
Joe you're done we got to blame this on
somebody and guess what then they will
become more radical and that's what
Newsome is banking on the party will
become more radical because
who would you want if you were becoming
more radical more communistic more
Marxist more big government more high
taxes more gender nonsense more all the
stuff well who would be perfect for that
it would be a lizard man from California
so what are some of the things that
Gavin Newsom has done wrong well one
thing is he got rid of 350 000 people
that fled California in 2021 and that
was of course the second year in a row
that California had a net loss of
population would hit it which it had
never had before Gavin took over but he
also got everything wrong during covet
and I thought this would be a nice time
to remind us of some of that and that's
why we recognize our responsibility to
do more and that's what we are
announcing here today A Statewide
requirement for in-person instruction
for all of our children to add to a
well-established list that currently
includes 10 vaccinations and one
well-established rules and regulations
that have been Advanced by the
legislature for decades to add to that
list the vaccination for covet 19. we
intend to do that once the FDA has fully
approved the vaccine which will give us
time to work with districts give us time
to work with parents
okay so that was in October of 2021. now
Gavin Newsom who was closing down
schools even before that while sending
his own kid to private school that was
left opened and his kid wasn't wearing a
mask there he was demanding that all the
public schools mask their kids and get
uh you know get the injection and of
course we now know that it basically did
not work and that there was no reason
for kids to have it and all of the stuff
but he loves state power that's all this
man loves more than hair gel he loves
power and he loves I honestly believe he
loves ruining things because I don't
think you could look at his history look
what he did to San Francisco and look
what he's done to California and think
boy I'm doing a heck of a job but that's
Democrat privilege you can screw up
absolutely everything the media will
love you for it and you will get a
better and better job here he is
clashing with a reporter over some of
his uh let's just say unscientific
policies question is what's the we
understand the justification for masking
so my question is what's the point of
mandating it if there is no enforcement
if there's no teeth so as it relates to
the on the common area and I want to get
to your point I I answered it succinctly
by saying I have more faith than you do
in the capacity of people to do the
right thing so that's the response I'm
now broadening the response because I
think it deserves uh a more
comprehensive response
okay I'm not even going to show you the
comprehensive response because the first
part of what he said there was the evil
part that he has faith in people no he
does not everything he has done was to
shut down people force them to where
things force them to inject things you
know Crush businesses everything he has
no faith in people he has faith in
himself or something like that I suppose
but he has no faith in people of course
let's not forget he was also dining at
French Laundry perhaps the most
expensive restaurant and exclusive
restaurant in all of the United States
up in Napa Valley uh with lobbyists they
spent twelve thousand dollars on booze
at the height of the pandemic uh he is
just an absolutely awful human being and
this seems to be the direction that a
portion of the country wants to go and
now why would it be that a guy who
creates such destruction who ruins so
many lives uh who seems so deeply
inauthentic I mean if you thought Trump
was smug if that's what they thought
about Trump that Trump is smug this guy
is the smuggiest in smugtown okay but
why would certain amount of people be
Bamboozled by this sort of thing well
it's because a certain amount of people
are NPCs these are non-playable
characters who can't think for
themselves so they watch The View
we need somebody who can get the country
back on on line in line yeah because
it's you know it it if you can name me a
republican who has a shot yeah to do
that that's what I'm more interested in
because I think it'll death Santa I hope
it's not dead fantas over in Florida
because I think he's a fashionable I
think I think he handled covet miserably
I think he's a fascist and a bigot but
there's good points those are his good
points exactly
[Applause]
but but I do think there are plenty of
you know um Democrats that that have uh
tons of Verve and energy I mean I like
Gavin Newsom because he's really pretty
to look at and I think he does a great
job in California
how many of you just barfed
Connor had a little little vomit that he
just swallowed down even though we've
shown you that clip before and we played
it for ourselves right before the show
as we did our run through that woman is
so unbearable but I don't want to make
this about Sunny Houston I want to make
this about the ideas that she's talking
about there first off you just call him
death sentence you just call him the guy
who kept the state open the guy who has
the second oldest population in the
United States I don't know if you know
this if you ever saw the Golden Girls a
lot of old people in Florida and their
rates of covet and death and everything
else were basically on par with
California he fought to make sure people
could go to work and not ruin kids lives
and everything else I can tell you in
case you don't know it you all know how
much I love Florida everywhere I go here
there is such appreciation for this guy
there is such a zest for life here it is
the fact that I'm going to LA today it's
kind of funny this is the show we're
doing today I'm going back to Cali to LA
tonight and I just know I just know for
all the joy that you see in people's
faces here uh that it doesn't exist
there because I went back a couple
months ago and it was a nightmare this
opium awfulness whose idea was this trip
was your idea anyway
um so okay he's and then she you know
casually he's death saying this he's a
fascist and a bigot yes he's a fascist
he wants to use State and corporate
power together to stop people that's
literally what the Democrats were doing
with kovid right you were literally
trying to join have the federal
government Force companies to inject
their people with a experimental drug
that is that the most fascistic thing
that I can think of that is uh Philip K
dick level sci-fi fascism okay uh and
he's a bigot I mean it's just these
things are meaningless they are
absolutely meaningless he is not a bigot
he is not a homophobe or anything else
you may not like him because you don't
like functioning people who care about
America and care about Freedom what is
she like well Kevin you seems very
handsome he's not handsome he's gross I
I cannot imagine much more grow he's
gross he's absolutely disgusting let's
talk about real estate agents I trust
and then we'll continue you guys know
that buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be way worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why I
recommend real estate agents I trust
they work with only the best agents in
every Market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their Network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
Pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents they make the introduction and
then they follow you through the buying
or selling process to make sure that
you're satisfied the agents they work
with have long track records they're the
best sellers in the field they're part
of this audience they share your values
and they're almost anywhere you want to
go head on over to
realestateagentsitrust.com today give
them some basic info they will contact
you make an introduction to an agent in
your town you will leave California you
will move to Florida you come on over
and I'll make your chicken parm how does
that sound okay so
Gavin Newsom clearly planning to give
Joe Biden the boot Joe Biden is dead man
walking no matter what right he either
breaks down on his own or they just have
to take him out after the the disastrous
midterms and even if the midterms go
well it's just he's done he's obviously
done there is a Jimmy carter-esque
feeling to the entire Biden
Administration right now so Gavin Newsom
wants to get in and what by it's just so
incredible like think of the balls on
this guy to to so obviously have
destroyed so much right even if you talk
to a sort of just kind of brainwashed
average Democrat in California there's
very few people who think Gavin Newsom
has done well people do vote for him for
some reason the machine just has them
very confused and they seem to like eye
taxes and getting no return for it and
all that but that's One Direction the
country can go in and then I started
talking about the other direction the
other direction is Clarity the other
direction is Law and Order the other
direction is is I don't know kind of
pro-america pro-individual Rights and
pro-freedom and not injecting all of our
children with stuff when you don't know
what it is you may remember this one
from Ron DeSantis and what was right now
people are doing looking at the
researcher saying oh man the mass uh
will hurt the kids now we we banned the
mass in Florida
um with the legislature with the parents
Bill of Rights and and other actions but
you know the reality is that was not
grounded in data it was not grounded in
evidence they lied to us about the MRNA
shots they said if you take it you will
not get coveted that is false that is
not true and they continue to say even
now when the evidence is so overwhelming
that not only is that not true people
that have multiple boosters you know
you're you're definitely at risk of
getting it there's no question about
that so so it's just time and time again
I think you've seen ideology placed over
over data and evidence
okay so everything he said there was
true right you know it I know it I know
you know it you know I know it they know
we know it and some idiot's gonna still
vote for Gavin Newsom well the system
right now is absolutely freaking out
about Ron DeSantis again I have no idea
genuinely no idea if he's going to run
for president I know this guy loves
Florida I know he's got a he's got to
and he will crush it in his re-election
uh which is coming up basically in a
month from now here in Florida I have no
idea what his plans are but you can feel
the machine we've shown you the New York
Times magazine piece on him you could or
there's all these stories now and on CNN
every day they're trying to pit him
against Trump and now he's even worse
than Trump right this is the move just
don't forget it the move is the santis
is worse than Trump trump was you know
he was mean and he was a big and he was
racist but he was kind of incompetent
and you know he was eccentric that's
what New York Times called him yesterday
but DeSantis is all the bad things about
Trump and he's functional so he's doubly
evil evil to the max so they really want
to take out DeSantis so here is a video
this is from yesterday this is a Texas
Sheriff by the name of Javier Salazar in
Bexar County and he has no love for Ron
DeSantis and he's going to investigate
that Ron DeSantis dare sent those
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
we are opening up a case uh with an
investigation with regard to the
suspected uh activities involving the 48
migrants from Venezuela that as we
understand it at this point the facts of
the case at this point 48 migrants were
lured I will use the word Lord under
false pretenses uh on into into staying
at a hotel for a couple of days they
were taken by airplane at a certain
point they were shuttled to an airplane
where they were flown to Florida and
then eventually flown to Martha's
Vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have then
what for what we can gather for nothing
for little more than a photo op video up
and then they were unceremoniously
stranded in Martha's Vineyard
okay so this guy is a clown this is
completely ridiculous nothing's going to
come of it you don't need to know his
name or anything else but what's
interesting is that he's saying that
they were lured that Ron DeSantis set up
his trap to send them to evil Martha's
Vineyard I don't know why the people of
Martha's Vineyard wouldn't have wanted a
little diversity in Richmond but okay
let's just put that aside for they were
lured and that's what he's upset about
but shouldn't this guy be upset that our
Administration which has basically told
people to come here basically said that
the border is porous this is what all
the immigrants that are coming through
they say it on television they literally
walk through the border and they're like
Joe told us to come hey uh shouldn't he
be upset that that was the luring that
by not having a protected border we are
either in fact or de facto telling
people to come over that would be the
issue but anyway you can see this you
can see what's happening here they
really want to take out DeSantis now
because DeSantis unlike virtually every
Lefty politician but most Republicans
too DeSantis does what he says he's
going to do he said he was going to do
this you bring him here we're going to
ship them out and we're going to ship
them to DC and New York and Martha's
Vineyard and everything else and the guy
got 12 million freaking dollars in the
state budget with the with the Democrats
signing it to do just this and that's
why they're freaking out because he's uh
he's Trump meaning he's racist but he's
incompetent because he gets the money
and he gets them to sign off on it well
he's not taken the criticism lying down
we've had millions of people
millions of people come across illegally
since Biden has been president did you
see any spasms from the media because
there are all these illegals coming
across the border for the last almost
two years no you didn't hear anything
did you hear when you had migrants dying
in the Rio Grande River or 53 migrants
dying in a trailer in Texas did you hear
a big no I didn't hear very much at all
about it when you have criminal aliens
that have gotten across the border and
those criminal aliens then go and
victimize American citizens do you ever
hear anything about that by these folks
no when you have a record number of
fentanyl deaths because of the fentanyl
that is pouring across the border do you
ever hear the gnashing of teeth over
that I don't it's only
when 50 illegal aliens show up
at a very wealthy
spot
called Martha's Vineyard
that advertises itself as a sanctuary
City so they hit the jackpot to be able
to be in the wealthiest Sanctuary
jurisdiction in the world
[Applause]
it's pretty great it's pretty pretty
pretty good okay so now let's shift to
how the media is reacting to this
because I think and I said last week
when this whole story was breaking I
loved this Martha's Vineyard story
because it is a perfect red pill moment
the Stark difference between people who
believe in laws people who believe that
if you say something you do it and
people who just put up signs on their
lawn and actually don't stand by any of
it which is exactly what the people of
Martha's Vineyard did which is exactly
what the corporate press does which is
exactly what all the Democrats do Etc
you got it now I usually call MSNBC The
televised mental institution but after
watching the clip that I'm about to show
you guys right now I want to call it the
Muppet News Network here they are
talking about Ron DeSantis How can any
of this be legal Ellie on the Florida or
federal law
well it shouldn't be I think we need to
start there first I don't want to you
know give people false hope not every
evil sadistic Twisted bigoted racist
thing these people do is illegal some of
those evil sadistic racist bigoted
things are just allowed in this country
this is a country that has cut its teeth
on the force to coerce relocation of
non-white citizens throughout American
history this ain't new when Joe Biden
says that it's Un-American not sorry Mr
President this is strangely American
using uh non-white people weaponizing
them
um and carting them around the country
this is what this country has done in
the past
that guy he's half uh Dr Emmett Brown
from
Back to the Future half what give me
something like half whatever it doesn't
even nothing I say it doesn't matter you
get it it's just so ridiculous okay so
anyway you have people watching that
program not many people but you might
know someone that's watching that and I
think you have to do what the long line
of people did in the original airplane
movie if if someone is watching that
they're they're not well and you have to
line up and you have to smack them
across the face you have to slap them
and smack some sense into them that's
what you have to do
um but it's interesting because they're
they're in a complete meltdown and of
course it's just racist bigot and it
proves that America's racist and big and
somehow Biden's even a race is bigot and
the whole thing but then what happens is
and this is why this story is so great
even people who generally certainly are
not Republicans or conservatives and who
don't really understand these issues
suddenly something starts seeing me a
little off about this whole story
because if this was a sanctuary City
that loves diversity then you'd think
they would have just welcomed them in
and everything else but they literally
kick them off the island within 24 hours
they were out on the streets upset that
these people had come here okay there
were Facebook groups that were blowing
up about this it was nuts so anyway
there's this guy Charlemagne the God I
can't keep calling him that whatever his
real name is I don't think he's a real
God but he's a guy on he's got a Comedy
Central show we've played some clips of
him before uh certainly not a concern
you know he's a lefty basically but so I
would guess some sort of like
disgruntled Lefty something like that uh
he had his paddle on on Comedy Central
uh talking about what's going on here
with DeSantis and the Democrats months
Republican Governors have sent busloads
of illegal immigrants to Sanctuary
cities like New York DC and Chicago with
the message of if you like them so much
they're yours okay well just in time for
Hispanic Heritage Month Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis upped the game by sending
two playing folds of immigrants to the
east coast Elites favorite vacation
island Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts I
personally think it's genius
but I wish that Governors like Ron
DeSantis and Greg Abbott would give
Democratic Governors and Mayors more of
a heads up because then that would
expose the hypocrisy of the Democrats
which is they don't want immigrants here
either
all right so I honestly don't know who
those panelists were but like you know I
know how hard people work if you're if
you're in the biz like I know how hard
people work to get to be a panelist on a
show or to get a show or you know to sit
there and have someone put makeup on and
sit in front of the lights and have
people applaud for you and everything
else look to get all the way there
and then to be so miserable while you're
there it's just it's just the perfect
end result of leftist thinking so
Charlemagne basically gets it he says
this thing's kind of good because it's
exposing that the Democrats don't
believe any of the nonsense they're kind
of spewing now I he probably still
thinks DeSantis is racist or a bunch of
other bad stuff so I'm not making this
that that he fully gets it but the way
they just sit there and they have they
have really nothing to say because the
Democrats don't care about illegals the
Democrats if the Democrats cared about
illegals you would be for a strong
border everyone that is here in this
country if you look back at your lineage
right virtually everyone that is here
their families came here and hopefully
came legally with nothing made a better
life their kids are better off the
grandkids are better off Etc et cetera
and that still is possible
um but if you are just for allowing
anyone to come in do whatever they want
bring whatever culture they want
whatever all of the stuff all of the
crime that comes with it and then be on
the the Dole of the system while your
main driver of your political ethos is
that the system is evil at the exact
same time that is a recipe to destroy a
country so I don't know how you can
frame this in any other way than the
people that are really in charge on the
Democrat side want to destroy the
country and actually the rest of Biden's
policies in terms of energy and
everything else would kind of indicate
that but the point of showing you that
clip and I don't know who's watching
comedy central anymore is that there is
a little bit of it bubbling up right
that's a little bit bubbling up into
corporate Comedy Central is just
corporate Viacom programming and what
they're showing you on there is the
santis isn't pure evil maybe he wasn't
fully there on that but the Democrats do
suck on illegal immigration because they
don't care they don't care which is why
I started with that cold close today as
well or that the cold open today right
because the cold open was about a Border
Town and nobody cares about that border
town but they care when it shows up to
the we believe in science look we put it
on our lawn people so now let's bring it
all home because I am going to Los
Angeles California tonight I'm going
back into the belly of the Beast I'm
leaving the free state
for 48 hours and I'm going back to
California
to talk to Bill Maher so on Bill Maher's
podcast which is called Club random they
film it at his house that's where I'm
headed tomorrow uh Woody Harrelson you
guys know actor Woody Harrelson of
cheers and many other things over the
years he's a big pothead and he and Bill
were smoking some pot and talking about
government and Pharma and what I think
is interesting before I don't want to
lead it too much but what I think is
interesting about this is hmm couple
potheads sitting around realizing that
the government doesn't really do
anything good I like it most Americans
would not normally trust the government
with helping them you know like what
does the government actually do to help
you and they don't trust you they help
they help big corporations industry all
the people that got you know got those
people into Congress or ultimately to
become president those people all got to
get taken care of they don't trust the
CDC Americans we have the polling on
this is that true that is true okay so
here's the CDC promoting that we have to
do all of these things right I just I
don't like profiteering and War you know
think of the billions of dollars that
have gone to Big Pharma but I was
getting back to my original point the
last people I would trust with my health
his big Pharma and big government
because neither one of those strike me
as caring entities
I'd had Woody from cheers making some
sense going the libertarian route and
these are two guys who I think Woody
probably also lives in La I would guess
probably lives in California but Bill's
obviously right in the heart of LA and
Hollywood that whole thing and they're
they're getting it oh people don't trust
the government anymore they don't trust
the CDC and everything else now again
bill was for some of the lockdowns I
think at the beginning and four mass and
vaccines and all of those things I think
and I don't even need to fight about
every little thing with him but I'm
going to sit in that very chair tomorrow
and we'll talk about some of this stuff
but the point is uh what what do people
have to see at this point to realize
that the government does not work for
them and there is one set of political
we have two political main political
parties one set is just about expanding
the power of that thing and one is just
this imperfect usually pretty bad
version that is not really all for that
and sometimes can actually do some
really good stuff like here in Florida
that's kind of where we're at at the
moment and hopefully I'll get to share
some of those thoughts with Bill
tomorrow couple comments from the locals
community and then we got a cold close
for you tallway says Gavin Palpatine
gruesome yes Palpatine I feel like if I
had to choose to like spend the weekend
with either Palpatine or Newsome it's
Palpatine for sure like he's got
electricity out of his hands he's got
that laugh it's kind of infectious no
doubt Tony says I hope that Dave and the
crew have valid U.S passports because
they'll be going to the third world
and we'll need them to get back into the
real USA you bring in your passport
because it's true we're going this is
like we're going deep under you know
what I mean this is like Predator level
Margo says does anyone else wonder
whether these people actually know the
definitions of the words that they use
you know that's a good one because they
get so many things wrong they they call
everybody all of these things they they
wouldn't get you know when uh Sunny
Hosten says okay Ron DeSantis is a
fascist it means nothing in her brain
right the the sort of loose base version
of fascism that corporate power and
governmental power will be working
together to put you the little man down
like the supreme power these two these
two big things will combine and they
will control you that would be like a
very simple explanation of it and he
okay Rhonda's hand is just a fascist
it's like it just means nothing but what
it Gavin newsom's hands God she's gross
people we are going to be live streaming
from the NASDAQ floor on Thursday uh 10
a.m so the show will be an hour earlier
I'll have just done Ding I'm gonna go
God gosh darn ding the bell and uh it's
gonna be pretty cool tomorrow uh is a q
a for you that we're going to pre-tape
for you right now uh also next week
we've got oh no is it next week or this
week Tim Scott
we're doing it we're doing it this week
we'll do it live uh senator from South
Carolina Tim Scott is on the show and uh
good things are happening good things
are happening people all right we leave
you with the elderly man pretending to
be president and so folks I will take
care of this I will end this I will make
sure we have a plan I'm not going to
shut down the economy I'm going to shut
down the not going to shut down the
country I'm going to shut down the virus
I'm not going to shut down the economy
I'm not going to shut down the country
but I'm going to shut down the virus I'm
going to shut down the virus I'm going
to shut down the virus I'm going to shut
down the virus I'm going to shut down
the virus I'm going to shut down the
virus 220
000 Americans dead you hear nothing else
I say tonight
who this look there is no federal
solution this gets solved at a state
level anyone is responsible for that
many deaths should not remain as
president of the United States of
America
foreign
you can be around the vaccinated or
unvaccinated people we're going to
protect vaccinated workers from
unvaccinated co-workers the choice is
yours
you all made this possible this is not
about Freedom or personal choice